this deal has been weeks in the making
the final price tag a little bit smaller
than what was first reported what about
this deal excites you the most well you
know it's funny thinking about it even
though music is really what got Apple on
the trajectory that it's taken but has
gotten it to this extraordinary scale
and success beginning with the iPod they
have never done headphones well which is
very interesting in fact they even have
a policy at their stores that if you go
in and you have a broken head so and
they just replace it for free as my wife
pointed out because they know the
headphones are so bad so ironically
that's not being discussed too much
about the field they need better
headphones and they also need a broader
market positioning among young people
who I think many of them perceive Apple
is sort of an old person's product I'll
be at a high quality one so I think it's
probably a smart move to broaden their
market share to get into an area that
was critical for a heavily music
oriented company bring in some good
intellectual DNA in dr. Dre and Jimmy
Iovine and also it's chump change for
them because they got 150 billion in
cash yeah and they're only laying out
2.6 billion in cash for this deal so you
mentioned that they're buying hardware
they're buying cool what about the fact
that this is a talent play as you
mentioned that intellectual DNA of Jimmy
Iovine and dr. Dre what can it what can
that mean for Apple in the next six
months you know I was just in sort of
thinking about coming getting on to talk
to you I was reading about Jimmy Iovine
and all the records he's produced you
know like Bruce Springsteen's first
album you know to pick one of the
pretenders great albums that amazing you
know classic buy a meat loaf of bat out
of hell the guy has an incredible sense
of what people want it's you know I
don't think he's a Steve Jobs but I
think you know from an intuition point
of view he is somebody who gets how
people think and he can make classic
products he's going full-time to Apple
he is a music producer and a music
industry executive but I think somebody
like that could really add a lot to the
culture of Apple you know David I
understand dr. Dre you know is also a
great artist who can sell he's sort of
not
it's clearly going full-time from what
I've been reading but I'm sure he'll add
a lot as well David I understand what
Apple is getting you've made that pretty
clear but I I think about the artists
where they're gonna be making 1/5 1 6
1/7 of the amount of money from
streaming revenues that they would have
gotten from downloads so is that really
sustainable long term from the point of
view of the artists well that's a
debated question right now you're
getting into the beats music service
which is a part of this we haven't yet
mentioned in this conversation but you
know I do think it has to be because
frankly this is the way we're all
getting our music and that's not going
back we're not going back to buying CDs
if we can't figure out a way for the
artists to make money with streaming and
online services like Spotify you know
the music industry is doomed and so I
don't think it's going to be doomed I
think musics too big a part of culture
for that to happen prices might go up
that would probably be great for a
company like Apple that's now going to
own an important streaming service in
addition to all its other music services
I don't think we're gonna keep buying
you know song ranked by the song on
iTunes
David the strength of your the Facebook
effect was your ability to look forward
to where Facebook would go I remember
the first time I ever heard stereo
crystal-clear it was a miracle
when stereo came in reach forward
where will this transaction be in five
years
well it's a great way to ask the
question Tom because I think quality of
music is what's going to be affected by
this and a number of other trends in the
industry right now you know we've gotten
used to getting our music with
tremendous convenience but in the
process we've sacrificed the quality of
the audio and someone like you who so
into music I'm sure has been acutely
acutely and painfully aware of that and
so have I I think the chances are good
that this will lead to concentrate more
on the quality as bandwidth goes up and
wireless it'll help it happen even
faster